welcome back everyone this is part four
in our series on distributed word
representations we're going to be
talking about basic re-weighting schemes
essentially i feel like we've been
faithful to the underlying counts in our
matrices for too long it's time to start
messing with them
here's some high level goals that we
have for rewriting we would like in
these matrices to amplify the
associations that are important and
trustworthy and unusual while
correspondingly de-emphasizing the
things that are mundane or quirky or
reflect errors or idiosyncrasies in the
data that we use
now of course absent a defined objective
function in the machine learning sense
this is going to remain a fuzzy goal but
we do have some quantitative hooks i
think we have this guiding intuition
that we would like to move away from raw
counts because frequency alone is
generally a poor proxy for the kind of
semantic information that we hope to
extract
so we can ask for each of the
re-weighting schemes that we consider
first how does it compare to the
underlying raw count values
if the scheme is just rescaling the
underlying counts it's probably not
worth the effort on the other hand if it
gives us a very different distribution
then at least we know that we're cooking
with fire when it comes to moving away
from raw frequency
there's a related question that i would
like us to have in mind what is the
overall distribution of values that the
re-weighting scheme delivers count
distributions are very skewed in a way
that can make them difficult to deal
with for lots of analytic and machine
learning methods so we might hope that
in re-weighting in addition to capturing
things that are important and
de-emphasizing things that are mundane
would also give us an overall
distribution of values that was more
tractable for these downstream
applications
and then finally i personally have a
goal that we would like to do no feature
selection based on counts or outside
resources like stock word dictionaries i
don't want to be filtering off parts of
the vocabulary a priori because for all
i know something that's a boring stop
word for one genre is actually an
important content word for another we
would like the method to sort of make
that decision
so let's start with the most basic kind
of scheme and this is a scheme that will
pay attention only to the row context
this is normalization so this is
actually a repeat from the lecture on
vector comparison l2 norming we have
calculate the l2 length as a fixed
quantity for each row vector and then
the length normalization of that row
vector is just taking each value in the
original vector and dividing it by that
fixed quantity the l2 length
there's a related and perhaps more
familiar notion which i've called
probability distribution where we follow
the same logic we just replace that
normalizing constant the l2 length with
the sum of all the elements in the
vectors but again we do this
element-wise division by that fixed
quantity to normalize the vector into a
probability distribution
i think both of these methods can be
powerful but the shame of them is that
they are paying attention only to the
row context for a given cell i j we're
looking just across the row i we're not
considering the context that could come
from the column j so let's begin to
correct that omission
here's kind of the star of our show in a
quiet sense this is the first scheme
we'll look at that pays attention to
both row and column context this is
observed over expected let's just go
through this notation here we have the
row sum i think that's intuitive
correspondingly the column sum the sum
of all values along the column and then
the sum for some matrix x is just the
sum of all the cell values in that
matrix
those are the raw materials for
calculating what's called the expected
value the expected value given a matrix
x for cell i j is the row sum times the
column sum
as the numerator divided by the sum of
all the values in the matrix
this is an expected quasi count it is
giving us the number we would expect if
the row and column were independent of
each other in the statistical sense and
that's the sense in which this is an
expectation
the observed over expected value simply
compare the observed value in the
numerator by that expected value
so in a bit more detail here's how the
calculations work we've got this tiny
little count matrix here let's look at
cell xa it's got a count of 34. that's
our observed count over here in the
numerator the denominator is the product
of the row sum and the column sum 45 by
81 divided by the sum of all the values
in this matrix which is 99. we repeat
that calculation for all the other cells
making the corresponding adjustments and
that gives us a completely reweighted
matrix
here's the intuition that was the
calculation let's think about why we
might want to do this so i've got here a
highly idealized little count matrix and
the conceit of this example is that keep
tabs in english is an idiom and
otherwise the word tabs alone doesn't
appear with many other words it's kind
of constrained to this idiomatic context
so we get a really high count for keep
tabs and a relatively low count for
enjoy tabs again because tabs doesn't
really associate with the word enjoy
on the right here i've got the expected
calculation and it comes out just like
we would hope the expected count for
keep tabs is merely 12.48
compare that with the observed count of
20. keep tabs is over represented
relative to our expectations in virtue
of the fact that the independence
assumption built into the expected
calculation is just not met here because
of the collocational effect
similarly the expected count for enjoy
tabs is 8.5 that's much larger than our
observation again because these are kind
of disassociated with each other in
virtue of the restricted distribution of
tabs
and that brings us to the really the
star of our shown in fact the star of a
lot of the remainder of this unit this
is point y is mutual information or pmi
pmi is simply observed over expected in
log space where we stipulate that the
log of zero is zero in a bit more detail
for a matrix x given cell i j the pmi
value is the log
of the observed count over the expected
count and that's it
many people find it more intuitive to
think of this in probabilistic terms
that's what i've done over here on the
right it's equivalent numerically but
for this kind of calculation we first
form a joint probability table
by just dividing all the cell values by
the total number of values in all the
cells
that gives us the joint probability
table and then the row probability and
the column probability are just summing
across the row and the column
respectively and again we multiply them
and that's kind of nice because then you
can see we really are testing an
independence assumption it's as though
we say we can multiply these
probabilities because they're
independent if the distribution is truly
independent that autumn match will be
observed and of course discrepancies are
the things that these matrices will
highlight
let's look at an example and there's one
thing that i want to track as we work
through this example and that's the cell
down here this lonely little one so this
is a count matrix i've got this as a
word by document matrix this is a very
flexible method and we'll apply it to
lots of matrix designs
over here i form the joint probability
table and i've got here the column sum
and the row sum corresponding to the
column and row probability these are the
raw ingredients
for the pmi matrix which is derived down
here by applying this calculation to all
these values
notice what's happened that lonely one
down here because it's in a very
infrequent row and a relatively
infrequent column it has the largest pmi
value in the resulting matrix now that
could be good because this could be a
very important event in which case we
want to amplify it on the other hand
nlp being what it is this could be just
a mistake in the data or something and
then this exaggerated value here could
turn out to be problematic it's
difficult to strike this balance but
it's worth keeping in mind as you work
with this method that it could amplify
not only important things but also
idiosyncratic things
positive pmi is an important variant of
pmi so important in fact that i would
like to think of it as the kind of
default view that we take on pmi for the
following reason
pmi is actually undefined where the
count is 0 because we need to take the
log of zero
so we had to stipulate that the log of
zero was zero for this calculation
however that's arguably not coherent if
you think about what the underlying
matrix represents what we're saying with
pmi is that larger than expected values
get a large pmi
smaller than expected values get a
smaller pmi that's good but when we
encounter a zero we place it right in
the middle and that's just strange
because a zero isn't evidence of
anything larger or smaller it doesn't
deserve to be in the middle of this if
anything we just don't know what to do
with the zero values
so this is arguably sort of incoherent
and the standard response to it is to
simply
turn all of the negative values into
zeros and that's positive pmi that's
defined here so we simply lop off all
the negative values by mapping them to
zero
and that at least restores the kind of
overall coherence of the claims where
all we're doing is reflecting the fact
that larger than expected counts have
large positive pmi and the rest are put
at zero
let's look briefly at a few other
re-weighting schemes starting with the
t-test the t-test is something that
you'll work with on the first assignment
you'll implement it it turns out to be a
very good re-rating scheme and i like it
because it obviously reflects many of
the same intuitions that guide the pmi
and observed over expected calculations
tf idf is quite different so this is
typically performed on word by document
matrices in the context of information
retrieval given some corpus of documents
d we're going to say that the term
frequency for a given cell
is that value divided by the sum of all
the values in the column giving us a
kind of probability of the word given
the document that we're in
and then the idf value
is the log of this quantity here this is
the number of corpora the number of
documents in our corpus that is the road
the column dimensionality divided by the
number of documents that contain the
target word and again we map log of zero
to zero the tf idf is the product of
those two values
i think this can be an outstanding
method for very large sparse matrices
like the word document one
conversely it is typically not well
behaved for very dense matrices like the
word by word ones that we've we're
favoring in this course the reason this
is this idf value it's very unlikely
that you would have a word that appeared
literally in every document
however in the context of very dense
word by word matrices it is possible for
some words to co-occur with every single
other word in which case you get an idf
value of zero which is probably not the
intended outcome for something that's
high frequency but might nonetheless be
important in the context of individual
documents
so i'd probably steer away from tf idf
unless you're working with a sparse
matrix design
and then even further afield from the
things we've discussed you might explore
using for example pairwise distance
matrices where i calculate the cosine
distance between every pair of words
along the rows and form a matrix on that
basis really different in its approach
and probably in its outcomes but it
could be very interesting
let's return to our central questions
remember for each one of these
rewritings we want to ask how does it
compare to the raw count values and what
overall distribution of values does it
deliver so let's do a bit of an
assessment of that i'm working with the
giga5 matrix that you can load as part
of the course materials that's gigaward
with a window of five and scaling of one
over n
up here in the left i have the raw
counts and the cell value along the
x-axis and the number of things that
have that value along the y-axis and you
can see that raw counts it's a very
difficult distribution first of all this
goes all the way up to about a hundred
million
so and starting from zero most things
have quantities that are close to zero
then you have this very long thin tail
of things that are very high frequency
this kind of highly skewed distribution
is difficult for many machine learning
methods both in terms of the skewed
towards zero and very low values and
also in terms of the range of these
x-axis values so we would like to move
away from it that's one motivating
reason
when we look at l2 norming and
probability distributions they do kind
of the same thing they are constraining
the cell values to be between 0 and 1 or
roughly that between 0 and one
but they still have a heavy skewed
toward things that are very small in
their adjusted values and their related
values
observed over expected is more extreme
in that as is itf idf so again
the observed over expected values range
quite high up to about almost 50 000
which is somewhat better than the raw
counts but it's still very large in
terms of its spread and we still have
that heavy skewed towards zero tf-idf
solves the range problem down here
because it's highly constrained in a set
of values but it still has a very heavy
skew looking a lot like the raw count
distribution
from this perspective it looks like pmi
and positive pmi are really steps
forward first of all for pmi this
distribution of cell values has this
nice sort of normal distribution and the
values themselves are pretty constrained
to like negative 10 to 10.
and then for positive pmi we simply lock
off all the negative values and make it
map to zero so it's more skewed towards
zero but not nearly as skewed as all
these other methods that we're looking
at
so this is looking like pmi and ppmi are
good choices here just from the point of
view of departing from the
raw counts and giving a subtractable
distribution
here's another perspective where we
directly compare in these matrices the
co-occurrence count on log scale so it's
viewable with the result the new
weighted cell value what we're looking
for here presumably is an overall lack
of correlation
i think we find that l2 norming and
probabilities are pretty good on this
score they kind of have low
correlations and they make good use of a
large part of the scale that they
operate on
observed over expected has a low
correlation with the cell counts which
it looks initially good but it has this
problem that the cell values are kind of
strangely distributed and this
correlation value might not even be
especially meaningful given that we have
a few outliers and then a whole lot of
things that are close to zero and tf idf
is frankly similar low correlation but
maybe not so trustworthy in terms of
that correlation value fundamentally
again these look like difficult
distributions of values to work with
again pmi and positive pmi look really
good
relatively low correlation so we've done
something meaningful and both of these
are making meaningful use of a
substantial part of the overall space
that they operate in we have lots of
different combinations of cell values
and underlying co-occurrence counts
something of a correlation but that
could be good but we're not locked into
that correlation so we've done something
meaningful
to wrap up let's do some relationships
and generalizations just some reminders
here so a theme running through nearly
all of these schemes is that we want to
rewrite a cell value relative to the
values we expect given the row and the
column and we would like to make use of
both of those notions of context
the magnitude of the counts might be
important just think about how
110 as a bit of evidence and a thousand
ten thousand as a bit of evidence might
be very different situations in terms of
the evidence that you have gathered
creating probability distributions and
length normalizing will obscure that
difference and that might be something
that you want to dwell on
pmi and experience will amplify the
values of counts that are tiny relative
to their rows and contents then they're
in columns that could be good because
that might be what you want to do find
the things that are really important and
unusual unfortunately with language data
we have to watch out that they might be
noise
and finally tfidf severely punishes
words that appear in many documents it
behaves oddly for dense matrices which
can can include the word by word
matrices that we're working with so you
might proceed with caution with that
particular rewriting scheme in the
context of this course
finally some code snippets i'm just
showing off that our vsm module in the
course repository makes it really easy
to do these re-weighting schemes a lot
all the ones that we've talked about and
more in fact
and returning to the end of our vector
comparison method you might recall that
i looked at the neighbors of bad in this
yelp 5 matrix and it really didn't look
good this does not look especially
semantically coherent
when i take those underlying counts and
i just adjust them by positive pmi i
start to see something that looks quite
semantically coherent and i think we're
starting to see the promise of these
methods and this is really just the
beginning in terms of surfacing
semantically coherent and interesting
information from these underlying counts